hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 35 hört zu und
spricht nach
wir haben ein museum besucht
wir haben am sonntag ein museum besucht
wir waren an einem konzert wir waren an
einem konzert wir waren letztes
wochenende an einem konzert wir waren
wochenende an einem konzert wo habt ihr
zu abend gegessen
doha
ihr zu abend gegessen wir haben in einem
restaurant zu abend gegessen
wir haben in einem restaurant zu abend
gegessen
ich habe einen ausflug gemacht ich habe
einen ausflug gemacht
ich habe mit meinem freund einen ausflug
gemacht
nach luzern gemacht
ich habe mit meinem freund einen ausflug
wir sind nach luzern gefahren
wir sind mit
dem zug nach luzern gefahren wir sind
mit dem zug nach luzern gefahren
wir sind letztes wochenende mit dem zug
nach luzern gefahren
wie hat dir luzern gefallen
luzern hat mir sehr gut gefallen
mir sehr gut gefallen wo habt ihr
übernachtet wo habt ihr übernachtet wir
haben in einem hotel übernachtet wir
haben auf einem zeltplatz übernachtet
wir haben auf einem zeltplatz
übernachtet wir haben in einer pension
übernachtet wir haben
einer pension übernachtet wir haben in
einer mietwohnung übernachtet wir haben
in einer mietwohnung übernachtet wir
haben in einer jugendherberge
übernachtet wir haben in einer
jugendherberge übernachtet
das hotel wie war das hotel
es war teuer
das hotel war günstig das hotel war
günstig die pens
nun war schmutzig die pension war
schmutzig die zimmer waren sauber
die zimmer waren sauber
der kellner war freundlich
das personal war hilfsbereit
das war ein tolles hotel das war ein
teures hotel das war ein
günstiges hotel das war ein günstiges
hotel das hotel war luxuriös das hotel
war luxuriös das war ein luxuriöses
hotel das war ein luxuriöses hotel das
essen war gut das essen war gut das war
ein gutes essen
das war ein gutes essen
hotel edelweiss portmann chris christie
hat man hier spricht brinker vom 10 239
das wifi in unserem zimmer funktioniert
nicht
haben sie das passwort eingegeben ja das
habe ich schon ausprobiert dann schicke
ich ihnen einen techniker vorbei dann
ist er hier kommt gleich vielen dank
bettina ich bewerte gerade unser hotel
auf reisehinweise punkt ch kannst du mir
helfen klar
zuerst die lage
die lage zehn minuten vom bahnhof und
das beste unsere zimmer hatte sogar
aussicht auf die kappe brücke und den
fluss wie viele punkte kann man
eigentlich geben 1 bis 4
dann für die lage 4 die location war
super einverstanden
wie hast du den service und das personal
empfunden alle angestellten waren sehr
höflich außer die rezeptionistin als wir
angekommen sind sie hat uns lange warten
lassen bis wir unsere koffer abgeben
konnten
sie war ein bisschen arrogant und
unhöflich ich würde hier nur zwei punkte
geben
obwohl die kellner beim frühstück und
die putzfrauen gang sehr nett und
zuvorkommend waren jetzt die bewertung
für die sauberkeit war das zimmer sauber
ja eigentlich schon das bett war frisch
bezogen der boden war gesaugt und die
spiegel und die toiletten geputzt aber
die badewanne war schmutzig das hat mich
gestört dass darf bei einem hotel in
dieser preisklasse nicht sein
hier würde ich nur einen punkt geben die
badewanne war nicht sauber
das darf nicht passieren stimmt
sauberkeit nur ein punkt nun zum
frühstück das frühstücksbuffet war super
es gab frischen fruchtsaft der kaffee
war sehr gut die gibt für die und
brötchen waren frisch und noch warm
die auswahl von käse und aufschnitt war
riesig für das frühstück würde ich vier
punkte geben
wie hast du geschlafen schlafen haben
wir geschlafen
im ernst jetzt wie war das bett war es
bequem das kissen war mir zu weich und
es war nur ein kissen da die matratze
vom etwa alt da haben schon viele leute
drauf geschlafen
außerdem hat man den lärm von draußen
gehört mitten in der nacht haben ein
paar betrunkene herum geschrieben also
für die bildqualität und die
schlafqualität würde ich dem hotel hier
nur einen punkt geben
das stimmt
[Musik]